it's 1918 four four terrible years more
than 40 countries have been mired in the
bloodshed of the biggest conflict so far
known to man countries across Europe
were caught up in the conflagration but
Africa too was drawn into what was truly
a world war a conflict that changed the
African continent forever this is the
story of the first world war told from
the African perspective
[Music]
more than 2 million Africans were killed
between 1914 and 1918 both civilians and
soldiers many were forced to fight for
their colonial masters France recruited
more Africans than any other colonial
power sending 450,000 troops from West
and North Africa to fight on the front
line in Europe against the Germans
African troops were also deployed on the
continent of Africa itself France still
commemorates the senegalese infantry who
helped to seize the German colony of
Togo the British also fought alongside
African troops against the Germans until
1918 African served as scouts Porter's
and cooks
[Music]
Germany also exploited Africa thousands
were forced into military service in
Tanzania the former German East Africa
that meant labor shortages in the fields
and there was widespread starvation the
economy collapsed around a million
people died in Eastern Africa as a
result the first world war changed the
map of Africa Germany's defeat meant the
loss of its colonies German East Africa
German Cameroon Togo and German
Southwest Africa were all taken over by
the victors as trophies of war
consequences are still being felt today
in Cameroon for example the former
colony was divided between Britain and
France with the French getting more than
four-fifths of the land after the end of
colonial rule in 1960 the divided
country was reunified but by no means
peacefully the english-speaking minority
felt abandoned by the central government
rebels are still fighting for their own
homeland and there are deaths nearly
every day
[Music]
Namibia wants German Southwest Africa
was not divided but placed under the
control of the League of Nations an
independent country was supposed to
emerge with the help of South Africa but
the South African government had other
ideas and ceased control just two years
after the end of the war South Africa
imposed its apartheid regime on the
Libya and oppressed the black population
until Namibia and independence in 1990
the First World War cost millions of
African lives both during the conflict
itself and in the years that followed
Germany's defeat led to the redrawing of
borders colonial power changed hands the
result seismic changes that are still
today at the root of conflicts in many
regions of Africa for many Africans the
end of the First World War did not bring
hope for liberation decades would have
to pass and another world war would have
to be fought before the decolonization
of Africa could finally be celebrated
[Music]